[Music]
oceanic ecosystems are threatened by a
lack of science-based fishery management
today for example 34 of the world's
major commercial fish species are
overfished and more than 23 billion
dollars of seafood is stolen annually
from the sea through illegal and
unregulated fishing also causing habitat
destruction this is why a free website
called globalfishingwatch.org
was launched by google in partnership
with other organizations such as oceana
and skytruth in 2016 to monitor phishing
activity globally and make it
transparent to anyone online for free
they use satellite technology cloud
computing and machine learning in order
to find navigation patterns
using a public signal received by a
gps-like device called the automatic
identification system or ais used by the
vessels in the sea
you can imagine tracking 60 million
points from vessels worldwide
quickly grows into a big data problem
so let's dive in and see how to approach
the problem
[Music]
thanks to data today we can understand
our natural world with far greater
richness than ever before by orders of
magnitude
this now empowers us to build amazing
apps that can help us solve complex
social and environmental challenges and
so in this series let's build an app
together meet brian who's worked at
google for over 14 years he's the
co-founder of global fishing watch
so to understand why we did global
fishing watch we first really had to
understand what the state of fishing at
a global level was in the world
and the stats were pretty sobering so
when you think of something like a tuna
or swordfish about 90 percent of that
species has disappeared in the last
generation or two
and when you look at
fish that actually end up on a plate
they talk about how about one in five or
twenty percent of those is considered iu
so illegal unreported or unregulated and
then when you finally look at fisheries
themselves they say that about 90 plus
percent of them were either at capacity
overfished or trying to recover
so when we started global fishing watch
i like to say that it wasn't possible
three years earlier it was barely
feasible when global fishing watch was
starting and now we we wonder how we
didn't do it sooner and from a pure
technology and machine learning
perspective our first versions of this
were rough heuristics it gave us a rough
sense of where a vessel might be and now
machine learning has evolved so far so
that we're able to not only see whether
or not a vessel is fishing based on how
it's moving we're also able to
differentiate the type of fishing that
they're doing
and so we've continued to say on the
cutting edge of machine learning as it
applies to the fundamental conservation
issues or policy issues that we're
addressing with efficiency i love this
project and definitely recommend
leveraging all the extensive work the
amazing global fishing watch teams have
made accessible on their website as well
as on their beautiful youtube channel so
within google
i feel really lucky that i get to work
on a team
whose focus is to make a positive change
in the world from an environmental or
societal perspective
i honestly don't think this would have
been possible without google willing to
invest in something like phishing that
isn't something you would normally
associate with google at the end of the
day it was about making information
universally accessible and digestible
very much part of our mission so to
actually build global fishing watch
we've really used the full suite of
google cloud platform products
fundamentally bigquery was the only tool
that was out there that was enabling us
to look at billions and billions of
these ship position reports and be able
to look at them not only over time but
also spatially just storing that alone
was the type of thing that didn't scale
to a lot of other areas but then the
ability to go in and analyze it in near
real time so it enables an analyst to
kind of see how this is unfolding and
tweak their algorithms as necessary
and if you're curious about how to make
a time series classification app that
includes latitude and longitudinal data
let me give you a quick tour using
google cloud tools
let's start with a snapshot of the
products used
first up is apache beam which is an open
source library that you run a google's
data processing service called dataflow
to create two data sets needed for
machine learning
one is for training and the other for
evaluation
next is tensorflow keras which is a high
level api library used to define a
machine learning model where we then
train in vertex ai
as for the data we get this from global
phishing watches github repository
it includes a ship's unique identifier
called maritime mobile service identity
or mmsi
which was broadcasted at different times
along with its lat long coordinates
distance from shore and port
its speed and its course at different
times of the day
the irregularity and time in which the
data is collected then requires us to
transform it into even hourly intervals
which we call time steps
the model uses a one-dimensional fully
convolutional network fcn because it
enables us to feed a variable number of
hourly time steps it assesses patterns
in the vessel's movements within each
window of time and as an output it
labels whether it is phishing or not now
for this type of supervised learning we
need training data that has fishing
labels and global fishing watch
performed the labor of love of manually
investigating and then producing over
140 000 label time ranges
and for context even though that's a
tiny subset relative to the massive data
set it's more than enough to build a
model
next we create the training and
evaluation data sets in parallel via an
apache beam pipeline running on dataflow
now from a data preparation standpoint
we ideally want to feed the model raw
data that resembles what we get from the
field in order to get predictions as new
data arrives
next we define the model using keras and
train it on vertex ai which is an api
with a client library and user interface
that enables you to train save deploy
and request predictions
after our model is trained we save it in
cloud storage and can either load it
into a python app deploy it as an
endpoint in vertex ai or in a web app
using cloud run serverless
infrastructure
we visualize the predictions in a free
jupiter notebook called colab using a
map visualization library
we can see the ship moving and changing
color when it's fishing and when it's
not according to the productions
[Music]
so what's next well in this video's
description is a detailed blog post some
friendly links and most importantly an
awesome lab built in collaboration with
my peer david which contains all the
code needed so you do not have to write
a single line and can interact with the
map yourself if you found this content
helpful by the way you can subscribe or
leave a comment on other ai for good use
cases you have in mind and community
before we end i'm going to leave you
with brian's fun fact about the project
it's really shaped kind of the way i go
out and the way i interact with nature
now
and it it just makes me really kind of
figure out what's around the corner for
the next thing
and there's so many incredible stories
of seeing what happens when you simply
put information in the hands of others
and how they go on and take that into
other areas
[Music]
you